[Musique]
les pirates infesté les maires depuis
des générations
je vis donc serment de les éliminer tous
c'est là qu'a paru ce gamin
jacques barrot
[Musique]
suivez le
maul va tout ce que j'avais il déclencha
ma fureur
les morts ont pris le commandement des
océans qui cherchent un avis une fille
et un pirate raconter la légende d'un
cruel capitaine espagnol qui traqua est
tous là des milliers top je ne dors pas
des hommes non non non des pirates des
pirates
bien connu un espagnol avec un en
espagne
il en a après vos jack
où est votre bateau votre équipage
votre pantalon jack sommet excuses de
quoi on parlait déjà et
plus cacher
trouve sparrow pour 1
à partir de maintenant nous sommes
alliés
les circonstances nous sommes bien plus
qu'à ça
[Musique]
le macaque
veut pas avoir de problème
ne pas te musée tous les jours
des rats pour ce qu'il m'a fait
c'est ça mon nom après jack je nagerai
jusqu'aux rives arrêté je vous en prie
non non on n'arrête pas vous allez bien
trop loin dans le bas du dos j'ai vu ses
filles temps à arriver bien plus si tu
avais fermer ton caca
[Musique]
chaque sport qui connaît ce pilote
seulement demain trouve sparrow pour moi
elle transmet lui un message de la part
du capitaine salazar lui
khélil qui a rendez vous avec la mort
peut lui dire demain je t'en prie
[Musique]